I know you are not strangers to this
incredible event you both have very busy
careers and lives you just gave birth
five weeks ago but yet you two are still
here to support such an incredible cause
why is that so important to you year
after year core I'll start with you we
know somebody who we've been a part of
for so many years because it touches us
in a very intimate way it's just so nice
to be here and see all these kids that
we've known for now how many years I
mean it's a sixth time we missed a few
because of Cove it's so exciting to like
get back to it I actually I really
missed it and even though we had our
baby I had this on the calendar for so
long I'm like we are going to that we
are not missing that um it's very close
to our hearts and there's a huge turnout
today too which is amazing it's one of
the you know I think worst things you
could see and be and and so our manager
son and and someone that we work with
has it and we've known him for a very
long time and um EB is a really tough
thing and so we're just here to lend our
voices as long as we can and get rid of
this horrendous thing for our future
kids now that you're a new mama does it
make it more meaningfully for you too
like yeah
I mean it the word yeah well you know
I've never thought I would be a mom and
so like I see these kids out there and I
just I can't imagine if my kid was yeah
know like hurting all the time so I felt
this way before but obviously you don't
know until you have one
um and so I take it for granted totally
yeah you totally take it for granted so
I just wouldn't if there's not another
child that gets Afflicted with this like
I we just we have to do something when
did you first learn about EB was it when
you started working with the family we
have my manager Cynthia ped and her
sister is Andrea and Brandon is now 19
years old so we've known about it for
that long and there's so many Charities
and things to be involved in because you
want to give to everything yeah and
they're such an incredible family I mean
Andrea and Paul are two of the most
amazing human beings to walk this planet
and Brandon is also absolutely
incredible you would never know anything
even goes on with them and you know how
much care it takes for these kids and
like and how much pain they are truly in
um is unimaginable and um it just
shouldn't be a thing like I can't wrap
my brain around that it's still
happening but the research that they're
doing and money that that we're raising
continue with research and trying to
find a cure for this in any which way
possible and that's why events like
these are so important so important yes
and Courtney your daughter is around the
same age as Brandon and I know she'll be
here today too I imagine you know how do
you to want to continue to instill the
importance of giving back with your
children well just I'm so glad she's
coming today because I think it's
important for people to see
reality but to really you know
what other people have to go through
and you know I'm glad she's going to be
here I'm going to enter well she's been
here before but I mean it's it's just so
nice to see these kids and you know
they're so they're so happy to be here
and yeah that's the best part how do you
hope to instill the importance of giving
back the sweet Matilda oh my gosh um you
know just trying to be an example and
keep doing the things that I'm doing now
and um yeah like she said being out here
and seeing these kids and you know we
see a lot of them most of them year
after year and um I I it's I hope that
Matilda knows that she's very lucky and
she's healthy and like we I guess having
a baby when that happens and they are
healthy it you do take it for granted
because you're like oh my God
I can't imagine like something being
wrong you know with her so I'm my eyes
are much more open than they were before
and they were wide open before so it's a
it's a very good thing what is it like
what how would you describe these events
because like I said you two are no
strangers to these events you you lend
your time well you know year after year
it's a really fun event I mean Andrea
and Paul had put together this
organization they like Kaylee said
they're patients they're tenacity their
Drive they're and everything they do
they've taken stride what somebody else
would just collapse they keep going and
they keep doing it and they have the
best attitude but they put on this event
at this beautiful home overlooking the
water I um personally I I've been
bringing in the good music Acts
Andrea told me you had a big say you
asked her did you just ask her straight
up no she's a really good friend of mine
oh yes didn't you really do this please
I bet I got asked not with her she's so
easy I didn't I I asked Ed it was of
course
Brandy's like of course it's not a hard
so you're the music coordinator
wow that's incredible Kaylee are you
ready I'm making some comedy out there
today
yeah so if you guys want to come over
there and grab some sushi I'll be
rolling Sushi amazing really excited
about it
um actually Sushi has been on my mind
because I haven't had it since I had
this baby so I'm actually very excited
but no this one I actually will be yeah
but no the sponsors could that come out
and the food and all the amazing things
it's really a huge event and rewinding a
little to Andrea and Paul I mean they
already have full-time jobs and actually
but this itself is a full-time job so
what they do we just want to help them
any which way that we can and like she
said we've we've known them basically
for this entire life so it's very
important to us how would you describe
Brandon I sat down with him you know
right before you and he's just he's so
remarkable I'm so proud of how far he's
come and the challenges he's overcome I
mean you know I don't really know what a
normal life is
um so I've lived with this ever since I
was born
um but I definitely faced some struggles
and sometimes like walking
um I mean every day is a different
challenge you two go way back with him
you know he's hilarious actually he's
dry very funny very dry I'm always like
what did she just say it's very
sarcastic and now you know now that he's
a young man he wants to use his voice
just as much as everybody else and like
I know he's doing speaking engagements
and he's very active on social media um
which is huge but he um he's very very
special human being and he's in college
now he wants to study film I feel like
you know maybe you too in the I'm very
busy I can't help Brandon with any of
that but maybe you could go to Courtney
I told Brandon don't come no I'm just
joking I don't help random with anything
that he needed
um he's a very special person what do
you hope that people take away from
seeing events like these happen and
seeing people like yourselves be a part
of it and and what do you want them to
know about EB how do they help
support I mean it you know it does take
money to have research and they're
they're making so many strides but need
more and you need awareness and so many
people don't know about this very very
right yeah rare disease and yes there
are a lot of celebrities out there there
are a lot of Charities that people get
asked to do but I'm always like please
please look at this one please see this
one because you will want to come to
this every year you will want to give
you'll want to donate you want to be a
voice you can't turn your back on it
like it's once you see it near part of
it you're in you know I think we
appreciate you both giving your time to
help spread awareness and this is gonna
this is a piece that is so close to my
heart I'm so honored to have been able
to be here as well thank you guys for
doing it too and thank you T because
it's these moments that we get to you
know say what we need to say and get it
out there and that's the most important
because again a lot of people don't know
what this is still in this day we've
been involved for so many years still
friends of mine I'm like I'm telling
they're like what is it like they still
don't know so it's keep talking about it
keep posting about it social media can
be a horrible thing but it also can be
an amazing thing for things like this
um buy the jewelry you know there are
things that you can how you can donate
and get gifts and all these amazing
things for your family and friends that
benefit EB you hurt her
foreign